vamos a calcular la fórmula de una
integral definida para calcular el
excedente de producción de vasos de
refresco para ello nos apoyaremos en una
gráfica donde observamos dos rectas que
nos muestran la relación de oferta y
demanda de este producto en el mercado
cada una de estas rectas está
representada por una ecuación la oferta
porque igual a 2 x 5 y la demanda porque
igual a menos x más 23 esas ecuaciones
nos ayudarán más adelante analicemos la
gráfica como puedes ver el eje i está
representando el precio de un producto
supongamos que podemos vender un vaso de
refresco mínimo en cinco pesos y máximo
en 23 así vemos que a mayor precio la
demanda baja
en el eje x se representa la cantidad de
vasos que se deben vender para recuperar
lo que se invirtió y para tener
ganancias esto nos permite ver que a
medida que el precio baja los
consumidores van a querer comprar más y
por eso la recta de la oferta sube al
trazar el punto de intersección entre
ambas rectas obtenemos el punto de
equilibrio que es el número de vasos de
refresco que deberán venderse como
mínimo para recuperar los gastos que se
invirtieron en la venta del producto
de acuerdo con la gráfica como mínimo se
deben vender 6 vasos de refresco a un
precio de 17 pesos logras observar que
al marcar estás últimas líneas punteadas
se forme un triángulo justamente vamos a
trabajar en esta área para aplicar
nuestra integral definida y calcular el
excedente de producción lo que vamos a
calcular son las ganancias de la venta
de vasos de refresco las cuales están
representadas en la gráfica por el área
asombrada en color amarillo entre el 5 y
el 17 en administración se le conoce
como excedente de producción
para calcular el área asombrada en
amarillo apliquemos la fórmula de una
integral definida
la integral desde a hasta de fx
diferencial de x
antes de sustituir los datos en nuestra
fórmula vamos a establecer el intervalo
donde queremos calcular el área ósea de
0 a 6 que son los puntos en el eje x que
vemos resaltados en color rosa después
nuestro precio de 17 pesos menos la
ecuación de nuestra demanda que es 2 x +
5 por la diferencial de x con estos
datos la fórmula quedaría de la
siguiente manera la integral de 0
de 17 menos 2 x 5 de diferencial de x
vamos a eliminar el paréntesis
multiplicando por menos 2 x 5 lo cual
queda simplificado como 17 menos cinco
como tenemos tres términos de nuestro
integral primero reduciremos términos
semejantes así que a 17 le arrestaremos
5 y nos da 12
entonces sería la integral de 0 a 6 de
12 menos 2x diferencial de x ahora vamos
a separar cada uno de estos términos
porque aplicaremos la propiedad que nos
dice que si existe la suma o resta de
dos o más funciones podemos distribuir
la integral entre cada término por lo
que nuestra expresión quedaría como la
integral de 0 a 6 de 12 diferencial de x
menos la integral de 0 a 6 de menos 2x
diferencial de x una vez separados vamos
a integrar cada uno de nuestros términos
para ello aplicaremos una segunda
propiedad que indica que al encontrarse
una constante ésta se puede sacar de la
integral en este caso el 12 aplicando la
propiedad nos queda 12 por la integral
de 0 a 6 diferencial de x
en seguida aplicaremos la siguiente
fórmula que nos ayudará a obtener la
integral de la diferencial de x
por lo tanto nuestra primera integral
queda así 12 x
para la integral de 0 a 6 de 2x
diferencial de x vamos a sacar el menos
y el 2 porque también son constantes
para esto aplicaremos otra fórmula que
es la integral de x a la n por la
diferencial de x que es igual a x a la n
1 sobre n 1
así que la segunda parte de la integral
queda menos 2 que son las constantes que
sacamos por x al cuadrado entre 2 que es
el resultado de nuestra integral después
resolver nuestra segunda integral si
dividimos el 2 entre 2 nos da como
resultado 1 quedando solamente menos x
al cuadrado vamos a juntar los dos
resultados de nuestras integrales menos
x al cuadrado más 2x y ahora vamos a
evaluar en el intervalo dado que es de 0
a 6 recuerda que para evaluar se
sustituye el valor que nos dieron para
los intervalos tomando en cuenta que
primero se evalúa el intervalo mayor en
este caso 6 y se resta el intervalo
menor o sea 0
finalmente obtenemos el valor de 36 que
corresponde al excedente de producción
lo cual representa las ganancias
adicionales que se tienen por la venta
de vasos de refresco